hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
a well implemented lims equals good data
integrity
i'm alexis cross of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
sartorius for more information about our
sponsor please visit their website at
sartorius.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please report your
problem
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
siri siegelstadt
the lead consultant at siegelstadt
consulting
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen siri you may
now begin
your presentation welcome
oh thank you very much for the
introduction and welcome to this
presentation on how limbs can help you
with data integrity
i believe that most limbs on the market
have the technical functions to help
the big question is if it has been
implemented correctly
and that depends on how the users have
implemented their limbs
during this presentation i will first
talk about what data integrity
is and how it's defined and then i will
talk about how limbs can help
my name is siri sigulstad i live in
norway
i have a degree in chemical engineering
and analytical chemistry
i worked with lims and quality assurance
since 1987.
i worked as a consultant since 1995
with lims quality assurance validation
of i.t systems
data integrity and a lot of other things
i've also participated in the eu
leonardo da vinci project
to create a master's degree in i.t
validation
and i taught my classes at university of
ghent belgium
in the leonardo da vinci project we were
supposed to create the classes based on
existing books but there were none that
covered what i needed so i wrote that
after that three-year project was
finished
data integrity would be would have been
easier if there was only one or two
standards
but there are many and they're also
frequently upgraded
this is an overview which i've included
with permission from chris burgess and
bob mcdowell
as we can see the pharmaceutical
regulators in both the u.s and the eu
have created their share
requirements additionally there is text
more or less hidden
in all the gmp glp gcp
medical devices etc regarding how to
document what
is done the probable best document to
start reading is the world health
organization who
good data and record management the
newest version is from 2016.
other requirements documents are from
pharmaceutical inspection
inspectors convention pics and there are
also a lot of guidance documents for
example from gamp
pda european compliance academy and apic
iso 17025 and other standards also have
focus on data integrity
and not the least the pharmaceutical
regulators have data integrity
high on their inspection plans these
days
i've added a few pictures from my
beautiful country and i hope you will
enjoy them
first in this presentation i will talk
about the terminology
related to data integrity records
management and data governance
to get into compliance is a long and
winding road
we can start by looking at the
definition of data integrity
here's from the world health
organization who
they state that data integrity is the
degree to which data are complete
consistent accurate trustworthy and
reliable
and that the characteristics of the data
are maintained throughout the data
lifecycle
this includes alcoa plus ccea
assuring data integrity requires a pro
quality and risk management systems
including adherence
to scientific principles and good
documentation practice
well we see that this includes some
cryptic letters alcoa plus
ccea so what do those mean
alcoa plus is the acronym that covers
the data integrity and what that is all
about
it's frequently written as alcoa plus
with a plus sign
and the plus includes the ccea so what
are these letters all about
alcoa is a for attributable
legible contemporaneous original
accurate plus the ccea which is
additional emphasis on these attributes
all of these attributes
being complete consistent enduring and
available
well they're still just words i will
explain them or actually
i will have some help from wh o and x5
and 21 cfr to 11 to explain them
the a in alcoa is for attributable
and the who states that information is
captured
in the record so that it's uniquely
identified as executed by the originator
of the data
that could be a person or a computer
system 21 cfr 211
the gmp the usgmp states
that attributable means identification
of the individual who performed an
activity
and here we're actually digging into the
audit trail which should be well
known to anybody who's worked with
electronic records in the pharmaceutical
industry
the past 25 years mind you there is no
requirement for using a computer system
so even paper records need to include
this correct information
the l in alcoa is for legible
and here we have a fantastic enormous
big sentence
from the world health organization
data are reliable understandable and
allow a clear picture of the sequencing
of steps or events in the record so that
all gxp
activities conducted can be fully
reconstructed by the people reviewing
these records at any point
during the record retention period set
by the applicable gxp
the 211 has a more pragmatic approach
can you read the electronic data
with any associated metadata or all the
written
entries on paper legible should also
extend to any original data that has
been changed or modified by an
authorised
individual so that the original entry is
not
obscured
now we get to the c it's for
contemporaneous which means at the same
time
and that is exactly how who explains it
contemporaneous data are data recorded
at the time they are
generated or observed and gmp states
that documented on paper or
electronically at the time of an
activity
both of them agree this means that it
shall be documented while you're working
on it and not
later
now we are the o which stands for
original
original data includes the first or
source capture
of data or information and all
subsequent data required to fully
reconstruct the conduct of the gxp
activities and there's more in the
details in the text
the gmp states that it's a written
observation or printout
or a certified copy thereof or an
electronic record
including all metadata of an activity
now this means really that you cannot
print out the results fill in the data
in another table and throw away the
printouts
furthermore you will have to have
documentation for all the surrounding
data that was needed to get this result
that means that you have to be able to
create recreate it completely
i'll explain more later which data we're
talking about
finally the second a in alcoa
which is for accurate and who states
that
the term accurate means that data are
correct truthful
complete valid and reliable whereas the
gmp states that no
errors in the original observation or
observations
no editing without documented amendments
audit trail entries by authorized
personnel
now the plus which covers the ccea
these are implicit in the requirements
in alcoa the record shall be complete
consistent enduring and available
complete we will look a bit more into
later
consistent is that things are done and
documented the same way
and enduring the data will last that is
stored in a secure way and they must be
available
this is all quite complicated especially
if we use a paper system
we will need not we will need logs for
which reagents as standards we used
and how they were made we will also lead
need logs for instrument maintenance
calibration
use and of course which of the same type
of instrument we used
the conclusion is that we do need a
limbs
so what is a lens and how can it help us
first of all
a lims is a laboratory information
management system
and it can take care of all the data in
the lab if we let it do that
the lab needs a limbs in order to record
everything that's prescribed
in alcoa plus the limbs must be
implemented so that all metadata is
available inside the system
no shortcuts and metadata i will explain
there should be electronic transfer of
data between limbs and instruments
and i will talk later about where the
original data shall be stored
first i would like to talk about static
and dynamic data in limbs
they are frequently called something
else in the different lymph systems
but i think you will understand which is
which
even if it's a different name that
you're using
the static data is that the lab tells
lims how the lab operates
that includes definitions of sample
types studies
analytical methods calculations in the
methods
instruments reagents and standards
and sample specifications users on their
access
to mention a few of the static data we
will have to populate the database with
our data and our way of working
when we start using the limbs live we
create dynamic data from for this sample
this instrument these reagents etc and
limbs will tell us how and which data we
shall collect
based on the static data that we've
already created
the static data are implemented in lims
which means added to the limbs before we
can use it for our samples
when that has been done we can add this
sample with batch number and so on and
the dynamic data are created for this
sample
if we try to explain this from a
paper-based lab static data would be the
analytical method descriptions and the
specifications for the sample type
the instrument sops and the reagent sops
to mention a few
dynamic data is the result for this
specific
sample or batch the log book for the
instrument etc
of course there are many more dynamic
data that will follow this sample to
make the
make it the way the alcoa plus describes
before limbs can be used the tables must
be populated with our static data
for workflows sample types studies
instruments
analytical methods specifications and
other limits
and the defined users with their
specific access
and all of these must be implemented
with care to fulfill the data integrity
requirements
let's look at an analytical method or
two and see how we can implement them in
order to be in compliance
because the alcoa plus is a lot more
than documenting the measurement itself
we must for example be able to prove
that we have and had
control over the instrument and its data
and we must have all the metadata in
order to be
able to recreate the data later
metadata well this may be a new
expression
but here are some examples
first let's look at reagents or
standards or chemicals
the original bottle or jar that's
purchased from a supplier
we create this in limbs so that we have
the following information
name purity concentration manufacturer
manufacturers batch number
internally given identification however
that is done
and when all this is entered we will let
limbs create a label which has the
relevant information
like this label here note the barcode on
the label
this is useful when we shall use the
chemical later
now we didn't need 35 percent
hydrochloric acid
or as a sample here some dry chemical
we need a thinner solution or even as
just a solution
and our analytical methods it states
weigh
approximately two gram accurately and
dissolve this to
100 milliliters we will include this
preparation in limbs
first we scan the original on the last
page
uh so limbs knows exactly which one we
have used
then we weigh these two grams and i
always thought it was funny to have
approximately and accurately for in the
same sentence but anyway we will weigh
these 2 grams
the balance is connected to limbs so
that we will send
the weight that when we're happy with
our 2 grams
and limbs knows that the volume is
always 100 milliliters and will then
automatically calculate the
concentration
limbs will also give this new reagent an
id and print out the label like the one
on the last slide
of course limbs will have to be told
first how to handle this as static data
when we shall use the reagent we can
scan the label and limbs knows exactly
which reagent we have used and the
concentration
this is often the input to an analytical
method and may be part of the
calculations in this method
we weigh things all the time in the lab
weight in itself is usually not a method
but it's a part of a lot of methods way
they sample and do
well whatever this means that we need a
limp that can handle
connecting at least two instruments to
the same analytical methods
some years ago not all the limses were
able to do that i think they are now
but add that to your user requirements
if you're planning to buy a new limbs
in fact all instruments need to be
defined in limbs
and the static data includes the
instrument information
type model serial number etc maintenance
information
frequency and what to be done this is a
sop requirement
when was it last done when is the next
time or a due date
that's the instrument logbook and can
the instrument be used after the due
date
it will be flagged if it has been used
if it is allowed to use it
calibration information is the same as
for maintenance that was on the last
slide
the next question is do we need some
sort of system suitability test before
use
in that case we need to create a method
for that
how is this instrument connected to
limbs one way
two ways
connection to limbs depends on how
complex the instrument is
simple instruments may only be able to
send information to limbs but not
receive from limbs
so the one way is always from the
instrument to
limbs with results more complex
instruments and all computerized
instruments can have a two-way
communication with limbs
here limbs tells the instrument about
method
sequence sample identification standards
control samples etc and receives the
result for each sample when that has
been analyzed
calculations may be done by the
instrument itself
or its computer system or we can let
limbs do that
for example the hplc with its
chromatography data system will do all
the calculations
and we'll send the final result back to
lims and keep the raw data in the
chromatography data system
whereas a balance may send the
measurement to limbs and limbs will do
the calculation
in the analytical method based on the
weight and
other factors
i mentioned that data may be stored in
limbs or
in the instrument how do we decide where
to store it
in general this is the first point of
entry to a software system that can
store and handle the data
so the rule of the thumb is that
limbs must store all data that the
instrument cannot store
for example balances and simple
instruments without computers
lymphs may also have file servers for
example for pictures from microscopes
a computerized instrument is generally
more suited to store a large amount of
raw data and to do the calculations for
these complex instruments
an examples would be chromatography data
system
atomic absorption icp ms
or those hyphen systems gc ms
etc however we must make sure that the
computerized instruments and downloading
their data to a server
so that data is backed up no solitary
instrument shall
exist in the lab network is alpha and
omega if we want to have our data
integrity
so hook them up
now we have several balances in the lab
and each of these need to be defined in
limbs
but they also need some dynamic data
when would
was it maintained last how long before
the next maintenance
same for calibration we have to set up
the
static data so it is not possible to use
the instrument
unless it has been maintained and
calibrated
or we can set it up so that we can use
it but then the result will be flagged
as obtained by an
instrument that has not been calibrated
or maintained
this is based on the dynamic data with
input each time
something happens to the instrument
now we can add the instrument this
specific instrument
to the weight data we receive when
weighing the samples
the previous balanced logbook is now in
limbs and is available at our
at our fingertips alcoa plus
and so it goes for all possible metadata
implement everything
don't leave anything out that has
relevance to data integrity
so let's talk about implementation of
analytical methods in limbs
ph methods are simple
you measure the ph make a note and
that's it right
no wrong with data integrity in mind you
will need to have a lot more information
you need to know which instrument was
used calibration and maintenance was
that okay
which electrode was used status age
checked etc
was it okay which standards were used
and if they were diluted how were they
diluted
did we use control samples well then we
need to
note make a note of those as well and
then we can do the sample measurements
so ph methods are not simple if you want
to talk about data integrity
here's another coral fissure where we
titrate to find water content of the
sample
when we enter this method as static data
that is
implement this in limbs there are
several considerations for how to do
this
we need a sample weight measured in
grams
which we get from a connected balance
when we set this method up as static
data we can either just state that we
need a balance and have the operator
input the
name of the balance used or we can say
that we always use this specific balance
which the operator can or cannot
overrule
if that is necessary and the can or
cannot is something you set up
we enter the type of standard that we
use so the operator can stand the label
scan the label on the standard that will
give information about the concentration
of the standard based on the id of the
standard
we scan the barcode
we enter what that we will use a coral
fissure instrument
if we had only one we can link that one
directly but if we have more
do the same way as with the balance
the instrument will give the titration
volume when the method is used for
example
finally we set up the calculation
formula so that limbs can calculate the
results based on concentration
weight volume and a conversion two
percent
this is what it will look like in limbs
when we use the karl fischer method
of course each limbs will have a
different layout but the basic
information is the same
we have logged the sample 2 2436a
in this case lims knows that this sample
shall have its water content determined
by the method called
water content by carl fisher weight
is entered electronically from the
balance and limbs then knows which
balance and its calibration information
we scan the barcode on the standards
bottle and limbs knows the concentration
expiration time and other information
we do the titration and the volume is
entered by the carl fisher instrument
and lims knows all about that instrument
as well
lims will then calculate the water
content for the sample
based on the calculation formula we had
entered
there is no need to use calculator or
excel
lims does it and as we have validated
the method and its calculations we know
that the calculation is correct
all the metadata is available and we
have the following alcoa
attributable legible contemporaneous
original accurate and the plus factors
follow also as we back data up from
limbs so that it
is complete consistent and durable
and available
now a little on the dynamic data as we
have entered the static data for all our
sample types instruments reagents
methods specifications
etc we can use limbs for the daily use
we have also connected the dots so that
lims knows that
this sample type needs these analytical
methods and
you have this defined specifications
as the analytical methods are also
connected to our reagents and our
instruments we have a good overview of
our data and where they come from
we receive a sample that shall be
analyzed
this has already been registered in lims
and has received a label with batch
number and other information
so we scan the label and limbs now knows
what we shall do with the sample
limbs will send the message to the
instrument to be used for example the
hplc
chromatography data system this may also
include run information
in the method to be used and the
sequence of the standards control
samples blanks and
samples lims will receive the analytical
data from the instruments
from the cds chromatography data system
there will be results that have already
been calculated based on the method
standards etc
for other methods like carl fisher lims
will calculate
the results limbs will then compare the
result with the specifications for the
sample and we
will flag if these are okay or out of
thick
we have also set up limbs to approve
results automatically if nothing has
been flagged
flags can be set for maintenance
calibration expiration dates problems
with system suitability testing
outer ranges for instruments out of spec
for results
to mention a few
a gxp sample should always have a final
approval by a qualified person like
someone in qa and lymph does have that
technical function for
electronic signature
i have a few general thoughts regarding
methods
when i implemented our new limbs in 1989
in a pharmaceutical company in oslo
we had to set the number of digits
globally for the whole limb system
we chose five as that was the maximum
that our balances could do
however it did not make any sense to
enter the number of dead mice with five
digits
one digit perhaps like 1.5 dead mice one
dead
and one half dead but that was about it
in today's lenses we can enter the
number of digits for each measurement
balances have a fixed number of digits
each so that number
is what we use when entering a weight
but lims
also makes a lot of calculations and we
need to have the correct
scientifically determined number of
digits based on method validation
don't forget that it shall be
scientifically sound
otherwise you're showing an accuracy
that you don't really have
visual inspection methods are manual and
not determined by instruments
in this example we have a spec stating
sample shall be white to off-white
fine-grained powder
how do we implement this in limbs well
we can say
paseo well pass is okay but what failed
uh let's try pass fail question for each
requirement
no we shall not pass fail is an
assessment
it is not the result we shall implement
this as
observations for each of the
requirements after all it's a visual
inspection method
we do not observe pass or fail
we observed if the sample is white of
white or another color
we observe if this is a fine grade
powder however that is defined
what so what we do is to create lists of
possible answers of color
white off-white yellow green or whatever
we need
the user shall choose one of these when
entering the answer in that way we also
avoid typos
we can also create a list of grain fine
grain
lumps coarse grains etc and finally we
will let
limbs make the assessment based on the
specification sample shall be white to
off-white fine-grained powder
if we laser have to change the spec and
run the sample against the new spec we
can see if it is still good
you cannot do that with a pass fail
results
another thing is that we may want to run
trends on the sample and a trend with
past past pass is not very useful
a trend with white white off-white white
gives information
electronic signatures
those are used in systems instead of
handwritten
signatures on paper that means that the
status is signed
it's used in limbs where requirements
for example the gxp
say that the item shall be signed
and please do not add more electronic
signatures than necessary
the audit trail will take care of other
information
like who did what we don't need a
signature saying that i did this
the other trail will do that
and the explanation for an audit trail
for those who are not familiar with it
each user is defined in the system with
his or her user id
and access to functions and data the
user has to log
in with his or her own credentials
before the system
gives access to the person the other
trail is automatically added
to every entry in lims and to every
change in existing data
the other trail includes the user id or
full name
date and time with our minute minutes
and sometimes also seconds
if the user makes a change to existing
data the system shall ask
why and the user must give a reason
these reasons should also be on a list
otherwise you will get reasons like
hungover
monday morning and friday evening which
is not very scientific
and believe me we saw those when you
left that open to the user
so create a list there are specific
requirements for functionality in
electronic systems for
e-signatures as stated in 21 cfr part 11
and the
eu equivalent gmp and x11
and the lenses will handle that
when you print it out for example in a
certificate of analysis
use a normal font and state that this
was electronically signed
do not copy a handwritten signature
don't scan it and copy it
that looks fake and also
the wh o states that a hybrid approach
may be used to sign electronic records
when the system lacks features for
electronic signatures
however the use of hybrid systems is
discouraged
discouraged and used of stored
digital images of a person's handwritten
signature to sign a document is
generally not acceptable
a hybrid system is
[Music]
may be used to sign electronic records
when the system
lacks features for electronic signatures
a hybrid system is a combination of
electronic data and paper data
it's strongly advised not to use those
hybrid systems
in fact the fda still allows them
but that permission i don't think will
last very long
so if you have a lims implement it so
that that can take care of everything
you need including electronic signatures
the functionality is there but you need
to utilize it
we have already discussed how to
implement various items in limbs
and limbs can be perfectly well adapted
for data integrity
but it can also be totally useless for
the purpose
unless you implement it in a good way
i think lewis carroll wrote this in a
good way when he wrote alice in
wonderland
in 1865 more than 150 years ago
it's old well-known and still valid
which way ought i go from here as dallas
that depends a good deal on where you
want to go said the cat
oh i don't much care when where said l
is
then it doesn't matter which way you go
said the cat
i think this is also very true for a
limb's implementation
and not the least for selecting a limbs
if you don't state what your needs are
then you will not get what you want
most of the large lenses have been
available for a long time and
will be okay for your purposes they are
not all that
different but you need to make it work
the way it should
thinking of data integrity from the very
beginning of the implementation phase
is important
first the selection of limbs is based on
the written user requirement
specification
also called iurs you will choose the
limbs based on this
however as each lims has so many
different ways of
solving your requirements the supplier
on you will generally create
a functional specification to fit their
system with your requirements
there will be several ways of solving
them and the supplier has good knowledge
of how their system works
in your urs you have also written
something about your workflow and this
shall of course be implemented as well
just a little bit of warning based on my
own experience
back in the 80s we had an r d lab where
people worked on one of 12 different
projects
this was the late 80s before we had any
sops to speak of
we realized that there were 12 different
ways of writing weight weight percent in
the r d
lab you can see that on the slide
as humans we easily see that this is the
same but a computer system does not
we decided to use one of them and people
from the 11 other projects were furious
about this stupid limbs that could not
handle their way of writing the unit
it was not that limps was stupid and
couldn't do it but in order to have some
sort of standardization for comparison
reports etc we had to choose one of them
one way to make work to make the work
better
is to standardize
i barely touched on lim's validation the
topic is actually a long class in itself
and we do not have time to get into
details
validation of limbs is well understood
now the book i wrote has a lot on
validation
and there are plenty of other
publications and books as well
i would also like to mention that gamp5
is an excellent source for it systems
validation
gamp also has other guidelines for other
i.t
related pharmaceutical topics
the lens itself needs at least these
documents
validation plan risk assessment use
requirement specification
functional specification implementation
plan
dq iq oqpq validation report
sops
additionally each instrument needs to be
qualified with roughly the same
documents as those listed here
and your analytical methods shall be
validated to see how they shall be used
so you can find out about accuracy
quantification limits and detection
limits
validation is expensive and it is a lot
of work
however not to validate is a lot more
expensive
that may mean that you will not be able
to get your products on the market or
have to withdraw what you have already
sent to the market
or even worse that you have to stop
production until the fda is happy
with your validation efforts that has
happened
that takes time is very costly a lot
more
costly than validation before you start
using
whatever you're using
uh i took part in the lims conferences
many years ago
what we heard was that more than 50 of
the projects failed
lims was not good for them but
actually that was not the root cause i
found that there are two
reasons why lims projects fail one
there's no user requirement
specification i remember alice in
wonderland
two the management was not involved in
this new
toy for the lab which i have heard it's
been expressed as
that means that when things need changed
like for example which system do we use
for the unit
or how do we change our workflows and
responsibilities
they didn't want to get involved they
may not
even tell people that it was mandatory
to use this new system
the result was a lot lot was left in
limbo and the project failed
today it's a lot better for once the
technology is better and people are used
to using computers for everything
another reason is that suppliers are
involved in the implementation phase for
example by writing a use the functional
specification together with the users
our supplier in the 80s rolled out the
tape on the deck machine and told us to
start implementing
and we did not have a clue about how to
do that
it is still possible for a limits
implementation project to fail
but it is not if we have good people and
a good organization around it
we need to have definition of tasks
borderlines between
define the borderlines between limbs and
other systems
and have some sort of culture change
management
well the same can be said for data
integrity it's expensive
i know two consultants who worked full
time for six months on getting the data
integrity
in a company in a good or in a lab
actually in a good condition
that sure is a lot more expensive
compared to doing it right from the
beginning
there are several tough challenges
though
because there are requirements good
records and data
management
as far as i can see there are four main
challenges
one management needs to be heavily
involved
and we all know how busy they are
personnel training and adherence to
requirements well it might be easier to
take a shortcut
documentations are both electronic on
our paper and how do we manage both in a
consistent way
outsourcing our work and services the
same rules for data integrity applies
as for our own work and how can we
ensure that that is good enough
well more details follow
requirements for data integrity is that
management shall be involved and that
means a lot more work for them than they
had before
the they are responsible for good data
management
they have to create realistic and
achievable expectations
monitor processes they need allocation
of necessary resources for this good
documentation practice
both internally and for the outsourced
services and suppliers
the adoption of the quality culture
which means it is okay to do
errors and to report errors but no
retributions
in many countries or cultures there are
there is a blame culture who can we
blame for what goes wrong
in any qualities driven environment what
goes
wrong is not who can we blame but what
can we learn from it so we can do it
better next time
this is also called kappa corrective
actions preventive actions
and stated in a lot of standards as the
main goal here is not to blame anyone
that will be a very big challenge in
many organizations and countries
in some cultures you cannot make
mistakes because it makes you lose face
for someone to admit that they made this
mistake before anyone found us
may be very hard
there's a lot of active items for the
management to do in order to be part of
the data integrity
they need to audit and review on a
regular basis
make sure that things are always
followed up facilitate the large amount
of resources needed for data integrity
issues
that includes quality manuals sops risk
and risk management
and not the least the daily overall
management
this will probably mean that more
management is needed in the organization
the employees also have a few new
challenges they need 100
adherence to good documentation practice
for both paper
and electronic records most of them are
already used to having to follow sops
for the smallest details
and as such data integrity is not really
news
but i do see that researchers who are
used to doing things and scarcely
documenting this especially if it work
fails so they have to repeat it
they may have a problem adjusting to
this new level of documentation
again it shall be possible to make
errors without distributions
as we are at least hopefully used to
from the
current quality systems we do know that
there is a need for independence in
tasks
time versus quality for example if we
can't finish the work with adequate
quality on friday evening
we'll just have to wait until we're
really done doing versus controlling
those who do the work shall of course
not control themselves
computer system access daily use versus
changes in system setup what do i mean
by this
you may have an application manager with
full access to everything in limbs
but he or she is also an analyst with
reduced taxes
that person needs to log out as an
application manager and log
in again as an analyst before entering
data from the lab
the person wears two hats and must be
aware of that
i've already said that a hybrid systems
are not good avoid paper if possible
it's hard to keep paper records and
electronic records consistent throughout
the life cycle
which record is the original how do you
make sure that a new version of the
certificate of
analysis is handled correctly and what
about the old version that we already
sent out to somebody
record-keeping methodologies and system
designed to facilitate
alcoa plus that means a zillion sops
if we have a hybrid system and a bit
fewer if we do this
electronically only and remember alcoa
plus applies to both
paper and electronic records
the fourth problem is outsourcing
you need to audit the provider before
the contract
you need really thorough contracts
include if the provider outsource their
own
work and services and that actually
frequently happens
with it suppliers or its services
make sure that they do understand that
this is expected
what is expected regarding documentation
and adherency requirements
and re-audit you will need to have your
own business in order to make outsourced
work in order
only then are you able to state the
requirements and the expectations that
you have for the outsourced partner
because you cannot expect them to do
more than you state
data lifecycle validation including
assessing risks and developing quality
risk mitigation strategies for the whole
cycle
well we covered validation a few slides
ago what i did not mention there was
that validation shall be risk-based
data itself also need a risk strategy
this includes controls to prevent and
detect risks
throughout the steps of data generation
and capture from an instrument
or from other sources
transmission between systems data
systems like lims or production
management system
between limbs and instruments between
all other computer systems that hold dxp
data
and while for example the financial
systems don't hold gxp data
they hold tax related data which also
will have to be under control from a
legal point of view
data processing how do we massage our
data calculate them report them
data review here we also need sops to
state who
when why and how data shall be reviewed
then data reporting and handling of
atypical and invalid data
data retention and retrieval and data
disposal we need to think about all of
this because this is the whole
data life cycle
data integrity risks are most likely to
incur
and be highest when the data processes
or specific process steps
are inconsistent subjective open to bias
unsecured unnecessarily complex or
redundant
duplicated undefined not well understood
if they are hybrid based on
proven assumptions and or not adhered to
good
documentation practice a lot of data
integrity risks here
data review is ultimately the
management's responsibility
but this is not very useful unless
everybody adheres to the standards and
do their jobs
they review and as appropriate evaluated
statistics
after the completion to determine if the
outcomes are
consistent if they're compliant with
established standards
they include all data also atypical
suspect rejected
reported data on electronic data
include the original records
the main difference from 21cfr part 11
work we did around 2000 was that 21cfr
part 11 was a job to be done
data integrity is unfortunately an
ongoing never-ending task it's a
lifestyle
more than a job
now what is kappa this is another
acronym meaning corrective actions and
preventive actions
kappa is included in the gxps as well as
in
iso 9001 and 17025 to mention a few
what it means is that we shall not only
correct mistakes
but also assess if anything can be done
to prevent them from happening the next
time
for example the instrument failed to
give the correct results and i am not
talking about the ins
that the results were out of spec or
something
but about other problems like the blind
did not meet the expected results
root cause was found to be that no
system suitability test was run
or something was not calibrated how do
we make sure that this does happen
another time or is it differently what
preventive actions can be made
we include the missing part in an sop or
inside the
method or whatever is appropriate
needless to say document the whole error
and actions
kappa for issues found for example
errors
you need to assess the impact on patient
safety product quality
information reliability need to
interview people to understand
nature of the failure and people
includes technicians
supervisors qa management staff
need to find out what can could be done
differently to prevent undetected issues
sooner which also is the underlying
root causes
i hope you learned something during this
presentation
at least you now have a grasp of what
data integrity is all about and what
standards apply
even if your organization do not have to
follow
that standard has a lot of useful
information to help you understand the
gxps
and vice versa the gap guide on data
integrity is also
very useful and should be read and
adhered to
granted the text there is not a
requirement
but the fda strongly advises that camp
four or five should be used and i'm sure
that would also be true for the data
integrity of the guide and for those of
you who have a limbs or plan to purchase
one
the lymph section here in this
presentation will hopefully be a good
source
of input to your implementation or
changes to the limbs
participants in this meeting are welcome
to contact me for short questions
and short answers will be free of charge
but as i work as a consultant
everything requiring a very long answer
or assessments
will be a job for me and will be charged
just ask i'll let you know
if it's a long answer or not
this was really my presentation but i
have a few little extra information for
you
in case you're interested
there are guidance for good data and
records management
there are some references
there is an excellent book on data
integrity and data governance by bob
mcdowell
so if you're interested in data
integrity and data governance
this is really the book to buy
u.s and eu pharma regulations or
information here
gamp it's not gamp.org but it's ispe.org
and has a lot of good guides
both um the gamp5
the ispe game records and the
data integrity guide from 2017 there are
several other guidelines to camps
regarding special fields like testing
validation of lab instruments etc
there are some standards organizations
here in case you want to
purchase or look at those standards iso
astm i triple e
i have some examples for juicy warning
letters in case you don't really believe
what i've said is necessary
uh one from fresenius carby in germany
2013.
these warning letters are from the fda
by the way
samples data and results outside of the
local systems
they have unofficially pre-tested
samples with selecting
selected reporting called test trial and
demo
out of specifications or undesirable
results were ignored and not
investigated
they retested without reason and only
passing results considered valid for
release
they had some unauthorized changes of
electronic data
permitted manufacturer management were
unaware of impact on
api their risk management was not
functioning
they were combining an out of spec batch
with another one to make it pass for
impurities
combinations of inadequate sops
inefficient training and corporate audit
data
audits fail to identify identifications
i would not like to be the receiver of
this one
there's another one from india 2014
the documentation was written after it
was done they backdated weight printouts
produced after
analysis where it was used for
calculations
they failed to detect and investigate
the inaccurate data found by the
inspectors
they have unauthorized access to
computer systems
that could make changes in master
production documentation possible
the users were able to delete data the
other trail is disabled for several
systems
shared logins for several systems and
operating systems
there were no backup of standalone gcs
and no control that backup has been
complete
another one from india incomplete lab
data missing raw data
trial hplc runs stored on separate
drives on personal computers
different from the normal runs original
data files were deleted
qa unit relied on incomplete records to
make better decisions
unauthorized personnel with access to
records analyst logged in with admin
account and no password
and the audit trails were turned on and
off
autistic titrator without named user
accounts
no other trail
destroy original batch records and
backdating voiced
replacement pages not very much like gmp
uh one from italy 2017
the records may be incomplete
original in unofficial and uncontrolled
spreadsheets on
shared computer drive later transcript
to an official form
the original data showed failing results
but reports show passing results
photocopied blank out of specification
form
and rewritten data critical lab results
where paper
were shredded
another one from india april 2017
the hplc software for impuritive permits
inhibit integration without scientific
justification
all the trail functionality was disabled
there was no review
it was exported to excel and it
there were no true copies or original
records
there was uncontrolled systems used for
auto specifications
missing scientific controls to prevent
data deletion
or alteration requested
records found shredded in the trash
these are just a couple or a few of the
warning letters that people have
received there
are plenty more but i think these would
prove
that the fda is really looking
at data integrity these days
and now we can do the q a portion
thank you siri for your informative
presentation
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left hand side of
your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started we've already got
some questions coming in from the
audience today so
siri we'll go ahead and start with this
one uh one audience member goes
we don't have a limbs and we don't plan
on getting one
so what do we do then well if you are
working uh on a paper-based lab what you
need
is a lot of sops and you'll need your
log books for all the instruments
and for how to create your reagents etc
basically what i've written for the
limbs but you need to have it
on paper instead so it's not really a
big difference in what you need to
document but there is a big difference
in
how you need to document it and how easy
it is to document
great thank you so much moving on to our
next question
we already have a lens how can we check
if this has been implemented well enough
uh what you will need to do is to go
through
uh with my presentation in your back
head
and see if you have actually covered
everything that is needed like all the
metadata for
the samples for the analytical methods
and
all of that so you need to go through
that again and check that
i think there were quite a few
ideas for you there and even if i only
covered a couple of
different analytical methods for example
i'm quite sure you
understand what i'm looking at and you
can
do that with your own data
thank you so much siri and it looks like
we have time for one more question
so we'll go ahead and go with this one
an audience member asks
we plan to get a limb which one is the
best
and or how do we choose one
well there are plenty of limb systems on
the market and
there is not one that is the best and i
think the reason there are so many on
the market is that they're all the best
for somebody and how you choose which
one
is to write your user requirement
specification and you will send that out
to
the vendors limbs vendors
and you will get the answers back and
the one that seems to fit your needs
best is the best one for you
and your neighbor may have another one
that's best for him or her
thank you siri before we go i would like
to thank the audience for joining us
today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration
we would like to once again thank siri
for her time today and her important
research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor sartorius
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now until next time bye
bye everyone